c'est désormais une tradition pour la
septième année consécutive la course
cycliste paris nice organisé jusqu'au 13
mars été lancés depuis les yvelines
cette année la ville de conflans sainte
honorine a été choisi pour le prologue
de cette soixante quatorzième édition on
est ravi d'être là avec un circuit de
complément qui va être sportivement
probant
le premier kilomètre je les ai long de
la seine et puis là la somme des
laveuses qu'il faudra escalader alors ce
sera certainement pas insurmontable pour
les croire de paris-nice mais ça peut
créer quelques différences
une centaine de coureurs étaient
présents sur ce prologue épinoy parmi
les têtes d'affiché le public a pu
apercevoir les stars françaises romain
bardet tony gallopin ou encore
l'espagnol alberto contador
il ya un très beau plateau avec contador
en effet avec richie porte le tenant du
titre donc deux doubles ancien vainqueur
de paris-nice et puis également avec
ceux que j'appelle les pépés flingueurs
thomas voeckler et sylvain chavanel les
cours en français les plus populaires on
sera heureux de revoir dans le casting
de ce paris nice on retrouve un enfant
du pays l'irlandais nicolas roche a vécu
à conflans sainte honorine jusqu'à ses
12 ans depuis cinq six ans à chaque fois
ça se rapprochait on n'était pas très
loin de saint germain en laye on était
juste derrière et je sais moi ya bien un
moment où on va tomber pile dessus
donc c'était que c'était qu'une question
de patience et et de temps mais
c'est bien que ça a été fait au moment
où je suis encore quoi l'australien
michael matthews a remporté ce prologue
de 6,1 km en devançant le hollandais tom
dumoulin d'une petite seconde